la ville n'est plus qu'un champ de ruine
vous désherbes akhmoud dans le Donbass
dévoile ses édifices éventrés rongé par
le feu ces rues jonchées de débris
soufflé par les explosions quotidiennes
à organiser
il doit aussi livrer ce modeste paquet
des médicaments des bougies
moi-même j'étais dans cette situation il
y a quelques mois à peine
il ne sait pas ce qu'il attend les
combats entre les forces ukrainiennes et
les Russes sont tous les jours plus
intenses
aujourd'hui mauvaise surprise une route
affaissée lui bloque l'entrée de la
ville
leur déconseille les routes secondaires
tout autour
l'homme dans la quarantaine n'est pas
plus à l'abri ici mais il refuse l'offre
d'être évacuée il veille sur sa mère
alité
elle ne peut pas il ne veut pas partir
mon frère lui est parti avec sa femme et
ses enfants ils avaient besoin de soins
mais qui va les traiter avec autant de
soldats blessés
ça démontre bien toute la volatilité de
la situation ici à barthout hier encore
cette route était praticable aujourd'hui
même les soldats que nous avons croisé
nous disent ne plus savoir par où passer
pour ravitailler les troupes
[Musique]
c'est devant une station-service tout
juste frappée que cela va nous donner
rendez-vous le lendemain il a un espoir
prudent d'arriver jusqu'à barthout et
ses habitants
c'est difficile dit-il comme dans toutes
les ondes de combat intenses mais les
gens ont besoin des tribués
Valérie un retraité de 68 ans est
visiblement heureux de revoir Slava mais
n'allez pas penser qu'il souhaite
quitter batmouth
je n'ai plus peur de rien de rien du
tout dit je vis sur ma terre ancestrale
je ne connais pas la peur cette terre a
vu naître il me donne de la force j'aime
bien
ce sont surtout les vieux comme lui qui
restent encore à batmouth incapable de
quitter ce qu'ils ont mis une vie
entière à construire il préfère assister
à l'effroyable spectacle de la
destruction en priant pour avoir la vie
sauve quand tout va s'arrêter
nous sommes à la maison voyons ce qui
arrivera dieu seul sait ce qu'il veut
mais espérons que tout ira bien
de ceux qui restent encore alors que les
rues se s’acharnent sur sa ville on dit
que la population attend l'armée de
Vladimir Poutine et son monde russe
cependant j'espère que personne ne pense
de mal de nous dit-elle si vous restez
ce n'est pas parce que vous attendez un
changement en parlant des Russes
elle le fait par obligation pour sa mère
mais elle est séparée de son fils à qui
elle envoie des colis avec l'aide de
Slava et son équipe
vous comprenez il n'y a rien de plus
difficile mes parents sont ici ils ne
veulent pas partir mon cœur et mon âme
sont déchirés en deux
seul ingallica et son copain accepteront
finalement d'être évacués l'appartement
du jeune couple a été bombardé la veille
ils n'ont plus rien
vos journées entières sont consacrées à
chercher quelque chose ce n'est pas une
vie c'est de la survie il faut partir
elle était restée jusque là pour son
père elle n'en peut plus pas toujours ça
non plus
il attend le monde russe dit-elle
heureuse
il devra l'attendre sans elle ce monde
russe
un délicat laisse une ville qu'elle ne
reconnaît plus elle ne verra plus jamais
backmouthel